a Sleek new Navy ship few of us knew
existed is in London after Sea Trials of
a Quantum navigation system designed to
give our armed forces the edge
we do have GPS but as has been
publicized recently sometimes that can
be interfered with or sometimes it
doesn't work so the ability to have a
new and novel way of accurately very
accurately plotting your position is
fundamental to the way the Royal Navy
and the military does business it's all
very James Bond
until you get to the technology itself
inside a shipping container surrounded
by scientists from Imperial College
we can't see inside the white box
containing the machine many of its
components are secret but a few miles
away in the labs where they developed it
is a prototype so this is a cold atom
interferometer at heart so we start by
cooling clouds of viridium 87 Athens
down to very very low temperatures so a
few micro Kelvin it's a few millionths
of a degree above absolute zero you can
see those rubidium atoms glowing red in
these pictures in this Quantum State the
particles also behave as waves allowing
the researchers to measure acceleration
and Pitch with Incredible precision
but real waves not Quantum ones are the
issue for practical navigation
controlling and measuring the subatomic
properties of matter is hard enough to
do in a laboratory setting so what this
trial is really about is seeing whether
a Quantum technology can even work out
at Sea and that's where the Navy's new
research ship comes in
so this is our first opportunity to take
our Quantum sensors out of the
laboratory clunky nylon straps holder
Precious Cargo floating Quantum matter
onto the deck this is a very exotic
environment for one of these kind of
sensors so one of the big challenges is
making it work in the real world where
things are moving magnetic fields are
changing there are lots of vibrations
that we need to manage to keep this
thing stable enough to be able to
operate it as it needs to work the trial
has shown promising results the team
hopes it will point the way to a new era
in navigation Tom Clark Sky News